hello everybody my name is Mark barn
welcome back to let's play the witches
house okay you guys told me quite a few
things that I need to learn about this
next part here on the first thing I need
to do is they need to go back in here
because the poison is now not affecting
and I can go see some things here dusty
old dress is nothing inside what is that
what is that what are you a headless
doll okay okay all right just roaches
not that bad okay so I got a headless
doll
Oh squishy squishy squishy with my fees
is there anything else that I need to
find back this way where did my dead
body go okay so looks like that's a
negative okay so anyway now I need to go
get the thing and people are telling me
that I'm getting close to the end
because people are saying very
explicitly that I need to not miss the
dresser before the end even PewDiePie
told me that I need to not miss the
dresser before the end so something
along those lines is there's a dresser
and I need to find that I didn't exit
wait I've already seen this okay no
don't read okay so now that I got the
headless doll I'm gonna go this way okay
top left bottom await top left top right
bottom left bottom right top left of the
numpad 7 7 9 1 3 7 9 1 3 it doesn't open
top left top right what are you talking
about well I died how many how many
roses wait hang on top left top right
hmm okay we got a little puzzle here
Asia I'm bad at puzzles okay let me
think here
let me think here
oh I just calm down for a second top
left top right bottom left bottom right
what could that possibly mean
what about were they mean top left top
right bottom left top left top right
give me mr. tree I'm sorry okay I'm
sorry for bothering you okay can't be oh
oh oh oh
puzzle brain exploding okay it's got to
be pretty simple
maybe I got to count the roaches that's
it
squish them all purple fluid does no
harm good good good good okay good good
good this is all Saul seems to be normal
here so top left top right bottom left
bottom right what could that mean it's
not the numpad top left top right bottom
left bottom right it's not the numpad so
what does this mean top left oh maybe I
just gotta look at like the room okay
bottom left times 666 okay re I got
bottom right plus top right okay
bottom left times 666 a bottom right -
top left okay this is a puzzle so the
bottom right - the top left and top and
the bottom and the top left is the
bottom right plus the top right and the
top right is the bottom left times 666
and the bottom right is six okay wait so
if the if that's the bottom right plus
the top right and the top right is the
bottom left times 666 and the bottom
right is minus the top left the top left
and the bottom right of the both is same
number which means that they're both six
which means that if the this is zero and
that means that bottom left times 666 is
still zero if they're both zero so six
zero zero six six eight six
yeah six zero zero six and six zero zero
six ah so smart with my burn
oh just 10 second to just ten seconds
ago saying you're I'm so dumb brains
blowed but look at me now I'm too smart
bandages and antiseptic solution Nadja
bottles filled with bones head medicine
medicine for your big fat head
Oh headache medicine cough drops
eyedrops my mistake I apologize hey
how's it going buddy
need some eyedrops it's a manga turn ik
throat medicine dot dot dot there's a
small bottle on the shelf
take it got a cute little bottle yippee
that's a doll's head I have a headless
doll body I have that oh no no what am I
supposed to do you son of a [ __ ] you
son of a [ __ ] damn it
well least I know the code damn it oh
six you're there six didn't change did
it good
come here let me lady
hellooo we're here hellooo okay so I
gotta get the dolls head and I got a
runaway from the horrible I monsters
curse me ish okay so pick it up
ah oh no oh good Oh where's there's some
fur left on the stump oh oh oh oh oh
squish squish uh-oh something not going
good here hello hello mr. kitty oh my
god
tree is dyed red oh I thought mr. kitty
was dead okay
whoo-hoo foo Kitty is not dead okay
let's see the rest over here he's dead
what's that sound
Oh summer oh the car goes idiot touch ah
oh yes me [ __ ] ha ha Mesmer is this
changed ok so anyway that hasn't changed
alright so nothing else besides that
munching on that flower can I go in here
ok cool beans
alright I'm just exploring a bit because
people told me that I need to explore
and if I miss something I'm gonna regret
at ooh mother abandoned me father didn't
notice me whoa they a little weird
hanging up plants no yes maybe so oh no
hmm good Ted I'm just exploring
everything to make sure that I've got
every ah
son of a [ __ ] son of a [ __ ] ok nothing
in there for me except death good great
fantastic
oh yeah judge was purple doll I think I
was trying to say that before purple
pedestal but purple doll placed all yay
hello oh look at that little hole piece
yeah uh uh-oh what's going on what's
going on what's going on what's going on
come to my room
why want to do that pair of Oz of roses
why why would I do this sudden seem good
why is everything normal things are
normal here okay things are normal
a lie girl lies that guy dead Oh kitty
cats dead Oh Oh squish take that cat
that's what you get for saving me all
those times he got abnormal oh no oh no
filled with many ribbons and accessories
packed tight with cute little outfits
goody goody gumdrops a spilled cup and a
blood full of bed a bed full of blood
mirrors fogged up I'm just trying to
make sure I get everything absolutely
everything because people told me not to
miss anything my sickness was going to
kill me so I took her body rubber I
lived on in her body
oh that's fine right no no let's define
because we're friends not friends we're
not friend laughs today we should play
some more how about know about new right
viola ha oh my god no no legless girl
LLL go I know going oh you're so nasty
of a saviour oh god you're so weird
there's no weird you're so weird guy
there's no weird oh you're so weird oh
you're weird
oh oh
get away get away I'm gonna buy this
[ __ ] nap I gotta find the shelf wherever
it was I don't know where it was the
bench dingy something I don't know
I don't know hey weirdo legless weirdo
you're so gross you're so gosu so curse
you so proud my where is the thing where
is it where Bob yes well that's stupid
where is this thing I don't know what is
oh yeah bye dad yes I know I know he's
gonna get me oh no I'm just having fun
now ah no running away gone up there
floor where are they were they were they
were not how am I supposed to forget
what she's right on my ass the whole
time
I mean I know I'm a cute girl with
golden braids and I probably got a fine
booty back there but God chinees dub
backup he needs to back off just a
little bit
give me holy ground okay where is it
thing now
where is it where I don't know ah maybe
I'm supposed to get out of the house
first and then try to get it cuz
obviously I'm not gonna be able to get
anything with her right all over me did
I mess up I think I messed up dammit not
ah um how much how I won't be able to
get anything ah sorry I'm not doing
their hand my hand load hang on
it's got to be away got to be away right
you gotta be some it's gotta be on the
way or some scheisse like that
something-something there some garbage
dump gimme pro dodges where where where
it was like ah yes it's not maybe it's
up in that way maybe there's a wait hang
on it was so quick it goes by so quick
because I'm sprinting for my life here
but hang on hey Lanie
I gotta find this good ending so many
people are depending on me finding this
ending give me are me turn him on a
black lab lab borrowed up so close it's
in that room it's got to be in that room
it's got to be in that room yeah no whoo
no oh no don't get me oh no oh no oh no
you over got me oh I'm so scared oh no
oh oh you're so creepy oh no oh you're
gonna get me I know you are
oh no ah yeah yeah I got some what I got
Ellen's knife I think it said I got a
knife did I get it did I get it
but did I get it what I need a knife why
I don't know was that worth it did I get
it did I get it did I get it if I didn't
get it I'll go back later but did I get
it I think I got it
hello is that a note pick up what does
it say read it dear viola I'm sorry for
yelling at you yesterday there's an old
legend that says a live live witch in
the forest and kidnapped children who
get sawed there your friend's house is
very near the forest so I was worried
about you your friend's name is Ellen
right
I don't Ellen's house was that her was
that Ellen bugs have taken up residence
in log this tree is dead I'm pretty sure
there's nothing here important for me
okay let's go think I got everything the
way is blocked by startling Hughley huge
let's cut it with the knife can't even
make a dent
what what the hell can't wait hang on I
wasn't close enough or the medicine
bottle on the roses swoosh killed all
the Roses and I gotta get the end egg am
I gonna get the real ending the one that
everyone's been telling me about
oh oh oh oh can I run now huh oh you're
so weird
there's all weird do it guys hi
stammering I'm boy you're stubborn
yeah did I get her
Oh
Oh
Oh
sorry I'm totally distracted because I'm
just paying very close attention to
what's going on now and he sent you that
letter what a good father I'll start
reading I was totally just reading by
myself I totally forgot that I was doing
a let's play here so then I was suppose
you're worried about what will happen
when you're gone it'll be just fine
I'll give him the olace share of love
and I'll take her share of love too so
viola huh Oh father father viola
are you safe are you hurt anywhere well
what why fear ah fo fum Oh father
duh da D stay away monster oh that's ah
ah man is this a good I have no idea but
Wow
whoa that's the end did I get the good
evening you know was that the one I
wanted was that the one I wanted was it
I have no idea I don't really know I
don't know but anyway that's pretty cool
because the whole time the whole time I
was the witch you know oh man Oh black
hat the whole time I was witch like long
like since the beginning of the game
what the black cat do like I did
something is there more
there gonna be more that's so cool that
was alcohol anyways so yeah what oh okay
oh man oh so cool I was Miss all time
and it was her viola in the which his
body trying to get her body back and
that explained why so many things were
kind of killer but also explained why
the house was letting me oh man I hope
that was a right and if I didn't get the
right ending that you guys wanted me to
see let me know in the comments below go
back to it because this was an amazing
game you know I said the beginning of
this let's play that I felt bad that I
kind of haven't played these RPG horror
games in a while because I thought I
didn't think that they would be scary
but man I was wrong that was probably
one of the best horror experiences that
I've had in a long time because it's
just like the jump scares were nice the
atmosphere perfect and once you get into
it and let yourself get into it and you
kind of have to play for yourself I'll
recommend if anyone's still skeptical
about these games like I understand I
was to give it a try
like playing for yourself same way you
would any other horror game like dark
headphones and just play for yourself
and I'm gonna play more I'm gonna play
more RPG horror games
you guys if you guys want me to so let
me know which one you would like me to
play next in the comments below or if I
miss something important in this one let
me know so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos that I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video bye
ah
good land away
oh hello